alright hey folks
let's see got a people all right let's
do this as you can see I am back in my
home we left South Carolina at the end I
think we arrived on the first first week
of November and it was we drove from
South Carolina where everything was
Green and we drove up it was really
crazy we're driving up you know through
Virginia and then finally up home and as
we were going we could we went through
fall so we started out green and then
the leaves were getting yellow as we
were moving up and then red and finally
brown and by the time we got to Montreal
there was snow on the ground and there's
been snow on the ground ever since we've
been here and it and it hasn't gone away
usually in November
snow lasts doesn't last it just falls on
the ground and then it just goes away so
yeah so I am happy to be back though to
get back into all my stuff I've been
trying to get my carvings in line and at
the same time I've been also trying to
get all these videos done all right I'm
gonna get these questions ready
but I'm happy to be back all right here
we go okay so I'm gonna start with the
questions and make sure I can see the
chat
one of the things I'm going to be doing
is going to be one of the things I'm
going to be doing before the new year is
get better organized in terms of in
terms of how I do the videos I do this
QA everything though all right here we
go
all right little more comments so we've
got 31 comments but I don't think that's
31 questions I think that's I think
people got into discussions on patreon
okay all right here we go
all right so Jacob Russell asks I used
to see hierarchy like a pyramid but now
I'm seeing it more like fractals this
makes much more sense when you say
Christ feels the hierarchy because you
literally see the same pattern through
the fractal am i onto something then he
says edit I just watch you're
encountering God and stories talk and I
see you've been saying this all along
for some reason I've been separating the
patterns you've been describing you've
been talking about with the hierarchies
jb has referenced now so here's the
thing the thing is that we can look at
we can look at patterns and the
hierarchies in different manners because
obviously their spiritual their
spiritual pattern so when you represent
them visually or mentally you know we we
we have to we have to give them a form
and so it is okay to represent
hierarchies sometimes as straight
hierarchies like a pyramid sometimes
that makes sense because you can
understand the way in which the one
moves to the many the way in which you
know identity gives essence to a
multiplicity all of that you can
understand by seeing seeing the notion
of the hierarchy in terms of the pyramid
but it's also helpful to understand the
patterns as fractals in the sense that
the the hierarchical structure will
reappear at every level of reality and
so for anything to exist it has to have
a certain amount of hierarchy because it
has to be something rather than
everything else and so that point of
something is already a different
different differentiation of quality
amongst all the potential that could be
and so just
differentiation of potential is already
setting up a hierarchy so just because
you say just naming something saying
this pulling something out of the out of
the potentiality is always a hierarchy
so it's you if you have something like a
let's say a microphone because I have a
microphone in front of me
the damn microphone has a structure
hierarchical structure it brings things
together there are certain elements of
the microphone which are essential some
things are secondary so there's this
hierarchy of manifestation but in each
element in the microphone has also its
own hierarchy you know each physical
element and also each let's say
functional element no matter how you put
it there has to be everything will lay
itself out into this hierarchy all right
I hope that happened the hope that
answers a question by the way Jacob I
have not forgotten the video about hair
I'm gonna do it I promise I've just it's
just been trying to get back here and
get everything organized yeah it's
coming it's coming all right I can't see
the chat which is annoying me
all right I think this is better
all right so in okay so what is the
symbolism of a river so the thing about
symbolism is most symbol symbols don't
function as alone and so most bowls
exist within a relational symbolism so
if for something that meaning it has to
be compared to other different things it
has to be in a story it has to be in a
pattern and so a river can have
different meanings it can a river can
mean it can represent let's say flowing
water or water coming from heaven like
water coming from above a river is
always water coming from above flowing
river flowing water water of life okay
compared to let's say the sea or you
know the bitter waters let's say the
idea of this water that's underneath and
so you have water that comes down and
then you have water that's below that's
still so the water that comes down can
represent a a kind of vivifying aspect
it gives life it's like it's it's a
spiritual influence let's say it's
someone something like rain and so but a
river can also represent the the same
kind of intermediary chaotic structure
that let's say the sea represents
depending on what story for example this
notion of crossing the Jordan in the
scripture and that in that story the
Jordan represents more the same thing as
crossing the Red Sea or crossing the
flood whereas in other aspects if we
talk about let's say Christ talks about
you know the difference between the well
and the living water which comes from
above and so the river can also
represent that living water that comes
from above all right that was Marco
Popovic who asked that question sorry I
need to always remember to name the
people who asked the questions all right
so
Laurey littie aho hope I'm pronouncing
that right asks about the video game
Myst and written by the brothers Rand
and Robin Miller I have not I've never
played those games so sadly I cannot
interpret those games for you I'm not
really
I have played video games you know and
it still once in a while I'll play video
games today but I've never really been a
gamer so the my video game experience is
rather limited
alright vladimir basu Bachchu asks would
you be interested in having a talk with
father John bear from the UK he's a
brilliant orthodox theologian and has
some very interesting talking points
especially on the mutation of the
attitude towards death in Western
culture yeah sure I would be happy to
talk to father John bear he was that st.
Vladimir's for a while I don't know if
he's still around I know there's been a
lot of changes at st. Vladimir's
seminary I would be very happy to to
talk to him
though the way that I choose my guest
ism is on my channel is really a mix of
happenstance and and let's say because I
want to talk about a specific thing
so sometimes it's someone who contacts
me who's interesting and and I and then
I kind of get them on the channel and
other times it's people who I know will
address certain subject like what I
talked to to to John Verve a key or when
I talked to father Stephen Freeman those
are people that I knew had certain
things to say which I thought would
would be interesting within the the
frame of what I had been talking about
and so father John I don't I I haven't
read that much from him and so I don't
know I would have to figure out what I
would talk to what we would talk about
alright so Laura shields asks my
question is about the continuing rise of
chaos Catholic Church Orthodox Church
our worldwide political system being
pulled into reactionary far right and
far left ideologies I think jbp does a
great job of identifying issues on the
left less intuitive when it comes to
what is
happening in Brazil and other
nationalist movements all right I'm not
I'm not sure that's a question let's see
she has another question is how do you
see as the best way to steer through
this disintegrate okay okay to steer
through this dissent there's a second
question sorry guys
so through this disintegration I have
become friends with the Benedictine monk
although Catholic he has deeply Eastern
Orthodox bent and has been extremely
helpful as Abba Paul says stay close to
Jesus I also went to the Marian Marian
pilgrimage site antinos so um I mean I
don't really know how to completely
steer through the disintegration the way
that that my let's I can just tell you
the way that I've been trying to do it
and it has to do with what you see in my
videos it has been - first of all try to
help people understand both sides of the
extreme to understand the left and the
right-hand to understand heaven and
earth and to understand that what it
looks like when one side starts to win
over the other when there's when there
isn't a balance between the two okay and
so doing that well in my hope in doing
that is that people will be able to
perceive the the the balance and then
try to to inhabit that balance as much
as they can and I think that for sure in
terms of practical manner the way I
think to steer through the
disintegration is to is to remember your
communities to to to focus on people
that are next to you folks to focus on
your family learn to love your neighbor
learn to love your family and then also
try to be connected to a community try
to be connected to especially a I think
the best is of course a church community
and there are reasons for that it's
because you know like these communities
online for example like let's say this
little community that we have you know
this little symbolic world community we
have it there's a Facebook group you
know there's a bit on Reddit and then
there's these different talks it's great
to to to encounter
people that think in similar ways and
and are kind of exploring similar
subjects as you are and I think that's
wonderful and it's very helpful but this
is also where we this is in this space
in these spaces is where we can create
these these so-called echo chambers and
so these are important I think they're
important when you want to learn and we
want to push this this this further but
then we always need to go back to our
actual communities where then you have
to face the person who is annoying and
you have to you know to face the person
who is who disagrees with you
politically or whatever it was in a
church you have all kinds of people and
so living in living within a community
is is a good way to foresee you can see
the the different aspects of reality in
different people and how people had
emphasized different parts of the let's
say of the cosmic story and so it makes
us less sensitive when people aren't in
line with the way we think all right so
Matthew Nagel asks just wondering if
there's anything you might want to say
regarding the incident with J Dyer I
totally understand it's not um there's
not much I want to say about that
uh you know so those who don't know J
Dyer is a youtuber he's a he's a writer
he wrote a book he's an extremely smart
person he has he's has a very very sharp
mind and and I think has a very good he
has a very profound theoretical
understanding of theology of the church
fathers he also is able to connect you
know the the church fathers to let's say
a way of seeing the world and uh in a
kind of metaphysical no join a kind of
metaphysical thinking with with with
theological and more practical thinking
and so he's a very smart guy and I had
been because he's on YouTube and because
we talk about similar subjects in
different ways I thought that we could
maybe at some point have a discussion
but you know there are a few things
about it I wasn't sure about
some people told me oh he's alright
others people were telling me different
things about him and so we had some
private discussions and we were kind of
I was kind of talking with him trying to
figure him out and he was also trying to
figure me out to see you know because
what I wanted I didn't want to have a
debate with him I wanted that if we're
going to do a video together that we
would do something that we were kind of
on the same side and talking about
things together and I don't totally
agree with the way he does things in
some ways I think that he we need people
like that in the church because he's
he's kind of a firebrand and he's
criticizing and he's he's you know he's
pointing the finger at people who are
kind of off the off the rails and you
know there's a lot of saints that are
like that in our store in our history
and so I think that people people like
that we need people like that I not like
that that's not my the way that I do
things I'm more concealer concealer Tory
I tend to want to to see the positive
aspects and and tried to build something
not to say that he doesn't I don't know
but I saw him being be more aggressive
and criticized different priests and
different organizations in in orthodoxy
and so we were discussing you know
totally in private you know I I don't
like talking about people usually in
public but then I think he saw it as I
think he took it as an insult and then
he started going after me on Twitter and
he finally blocked me and so that's
that's what happened so I'm kind of sad
I'm a kind of sad about that because
although I disagree with some of the
ways he does things I think that he's a
very very smart person and I think that
he also has a lot of people that have
you know found Christianity and found
traditional thinking through through his
analyses so so I don't know I just I
think it's too bad that that it happened
that way I kind of wish that we were we
would been able to work through it and
so you know that's life you know you
can't that's right I mean just keep
going alright so okay so
that was Matthew Nagle I think I said
all right so Nolan Watson asks I don't
remember where I heard this but Jordan
Peterson once spoke about religion in
terms of spirit and Dogma in essence he
applied his caste in order to Land's to
religion he said that it has a constant
balance of the two dogmas necessary to
hold things together but it must be
review fide by the spirit it seems to me
that the actions of a religion don't
really change although the deeper
implications of these axioms may be
better understood after time has passed
which could be considered as a renewal
perhaps this is what he meant
additionally I wonder if this way of
describing religion Foster's notions of
continual progression the idea of
Cuttino progression is attractive the
more I think about it the more I think
it's dangerous but I can't fully
articulate why seems like there needs to
be a point where things can come to an
end what do you think about this well
it's a there's a lot of stuff in what
you said I mean I think I'll try to deal
with the basic idea which is this notion
of what he calls dogma and spirit um I
mean I don't know if that's the right
way to say it but I do think that you're
definitely in in Christianity there is
what you would call the official
hierarchy of the church the actual it's
a structural part of the church which
has the canons and also the the bishops
and the priests and the way that you
know the way that you become a priest
and a bishop and the order of things and
we also have let's say a more we could
call it a prophetic part although I
don't know if if that's the right way
but we have science and we have
aesthetics we have sometimes extreme
aesthetics and those saints and ascetics
they tend to to act as a bulwark towards
the ossification of the church and or
the danger of the church becoming a you
know just this tyrannical hypocritical
thing it's mostly the hypocritical part
that's a that's the the thing that
Christ criticizes the most is is usually
not the structural part it's not the
fact that there are laws and that there
are that there is oh let's say a a
strict form
Christ doesn't actually criticize that
very much what he does criticize is
hypocrisy which is you have this form
but it's corrupt because you the people
who actually are supposed to inhabit the
hierarchy who have roles in the
hierarchy are actually undermining it by
their actions and so it becomes a kind
of law without body it becomes a you
know it's a come spirit without matter
right it becomes the spiritual part
without the the matter part and so
Christ is continuously asking us to
renew that not renew it in the sense of
a progress or in the sense of of this
kind of weird social progress idea that
we have today but renew it in the sense
of making it live again you know a good
example of this is for example in even
in you know in ancient times the the
Jews they had the Torah and the Torah
was written without vowels and so it was
just consonants and there were no snow
separation between the words and no
separation between the paragraphs it was
just this line this the stream of vowels
right of consonants and so that's the
this structure right and then the person
would take the the text and then by
reading it by vocalizing it would be
infusing let's say spirit into the into
the text and it's mostly in that way we
have to be able to live the the canons
and the rules and the liturgies and
you know the hierarchy of the church we
have to live it in a manner which is in
tune with its purpose which is the
healing of the the the the the body
which is the joining of the the church
with God in worship but also in
communion all these things that's the
purpose of the hierarchy you know and
once it derogate from that purpose then
it has become dead letter and so we have
to revivify it in that manner which was
bringing it back to its original purpose
but not so much in the terms of kind of
progressive social agendas and all that
stuff that
that is really a red herring in my
opinion
all right so Jacob Russell asks could
you talk about hi and icon icon makes
material sacred or is all material
essentially sacred or has sacredness to
it where does this sacredness begin and
end with a tattoo of the Theotokos be an
icon and trinity venerate it man
she's sure to screen written on a
t-shirt when you carve an icon when does
it become an icon worthy of veneration
and what if it if the piece is cast
carved away I think an image on a
computer could not be argued as sacred
because the manner in which it is being
presented to you is imaginary in a sense
it is an idea form it's technically ones
and zeroes a non-material image made by
material components it almost seems the
reverse of an icon this is a complicated
question for those who want a little bit
of an answer to that you can watch my
latest video that I just put up you can
find the link it's not public yet but
you can find the link on patreon or in
the on the Facebook group where I talk
about like icons and you know this ID
this problem of the problem of mass
production and reproduction and how it
affects the let's say the iconicity of
an icon so I'm not gonna go into it
right now I would say we check out that
check out that talk it's towards the end
it's in the question period if you don't
wanna listen to the whole talk you'll
find a question because that talks
exactly about that right so Jacob
Russell asked I was Jacob Russell and
Jacob Russell asked again last one how
would you describe Beauty scenes the
notion of in the eye of the beholder is
a very modern terms as its foundation is
in relativism there has to be a
benchmark doesn't there a hierarchy of
beauty yes it's a bit complicated I
think that I think that Beauty would be
when things fit together and so you know
that that sense let's say that you look
at something you look at a a tree or you
look at a just as it I had a scenery or
if you look at something and it ended
just right in the sense that the the the
way the things are put together are are
in a ordered proportion that there is a
note there's a sense of hierarchy
there's a sense of purposefulness but
also of I would say that I would say a
sense of proportionality things are are
in their place and so that is let's say
the the the higher aspect of beauty but
there's also I would say a I think
there's a lower aspect of beauty which
is a kind of particular is a ssin as
well and so they're all there can be we
see it now actually we if we we see it
today more than at any time in the in
the history of the world where things
can be too perfect so you can have
something which is perfectly structured
perfectly you know geometric perfectly
hierarchical like in like a geometric
shape but you can find images like that
you can find objects like that and
there's something lacking in in that
perfection like the perfection of a
mass-produced object whereas there's
also a an aspect of beauty which is
found in in the relationship between the
the hierarchical form and the accidental
and so you know when I talk about a
church and I talked about how the church
goes from the altar and there's this
hierarchy all the way to the outside
where you have the gargoyles I think
that that's the total that's the total
picture that say of the beautiful and so
Aidan Hart who's an iconographer that I
admire very much
he he lived in Mount Athos for several
years and I think is that simon petra
mount monastery anyways his elder there
i forget the name of the of the elder
that he was referring to but he said
that something about that there is such
a thing as perfect imperfection and in
perfect perfection in the sense that
when you look at an art object and you
see the humanity in it
because there is some something that's
slightly off you know in its in its in
its peripheries something that's not
totally perfect then it it also
participates in the beauty just like
let's say a a tree you know not no maple
is the same all maples have both
something which makes them a maple and
you can see the beauty of the maple but
there's also something in the maple
which makes it its own particular maple
and there's there's all that also
participates in the beauty and I
mentioned this in the last Q&A I think
talking about the difference between
Christian architecture and Islamic
architecture where Christian
architecture has a underlying pattern
which is very strict let's say but then
allows for this kind of this particular
is a ssin so it won't be just a square
and a dome you know with four corners
let's say like four minarets like a
mosque it has that structure underneath
but then you'll also have different you
know the transepts will be different and
they'll be there'll be different
variations on on this kind of basic
geometric pattern alright I think enough
on that
all right let me just want to mention
because someone we talked about did our
kangaroo dia says he can connect the
church fathers to mass conspiracy in a
fallacious way and he says unfortunately
Jay dart turned me away from going any
further in orthodoxy for now at least
yeah I don't know what to say about that
I'm not a big conspiracy guy not that I
don't think I think there are
conspiracies but I feel like because
these conspiracies are often so big and
so beyond us that I feel like it's much
better to pay attention to what's next
to you and to your immediate
surroundings you know it's like let's
say the entire church is corrupt because
it's run by freemasons I don't even know
if that's true if it's possible but that
question doesn't really ask you're not
asked to deal with that question but
you're asked to deal with is your priest
your bishop your priest who who who you
go to confession to and who will give
you penance and who will help you on
your journey now if you encounter in
that priest a heretic if you encounter
in that in your bishop who's directly
engaging with you if you if you
encounter in that person a heretic or a
you know a pedophile or something like
that then that definitely is your
problem and it's something that you have
to pray fervently about that you have to
look at ways it at how to to to be able
to deal with this confront this in a
manner which will which will be which
will not be a a desire to just to just
kind of out of resentment or out of the
desire to just blow everything up
and so but so I think these masks kind
of conspiracy questions in terms of
Orthodoxy I think that when we look at
them for two to much what happens is we
are we becoming capable of being engaged
in our actual community we become an
incapable of being Orthodox in a small
real way which is going to church taking
communion you know loving your
neighbor helping you the poor in your
parish looking around you
that's what being a Christian is so yeah
alright okay so Frank Raleigh asks what
do you see as the defining
characteristics of individuals who are
willing to travel far from the center as
opposed to those who did feel the need
to stay close to the center and everyone
in between I'm interested in symbolic
representation as they have appeared and
Christian literature as opposed to
modern-day psychological interpretations
although the comparison might be
interesting it's very difficult to
answer that question because because you
have you have characters usually the
characters the characters would actually
have a story usually our characters who
travel away from the center and come
back in some manner or or travel away
from the center in in some ways the the
characters who just are in the center
usually they don't have a story which is
fine sometimes you don't need a story
you know all the priests in in the Old
Testament that are named you know that's
what they were they were the center the
the high priests all the high priests
that don't have stories you know that
they they just stayed the course and
they were fine you know but usually
usually this all most of the stories in
the Bible represent the basic story of
the Bible like we talked about how this
Bible is a fractal structure and so it
is the fall and moving away from the
garden and then it kind of returned in
some manner to a stable order you know
so you have the fall then you have you
have Cain and Abel and then Seth
restores let's say a semblance of a
center then you have a fall fall fall
fall then you have Noah which goes all
the way to the end and then we
stores a kind of semblance of the center
so kind of have this this this story
that goes over and over but the
different aspects the different
characters have different aspects a good
example for example would two good
examples are you know the difference
between Joseph and King David you know
Joseph is the Exile of the center itself
that's what Joseph is so Joseph is the
just and he is cast out from Israel and
goes to to Egypt and carries with him
let's say the the the seed carries with
him his existence as the the seed which
holds the world together and then brings
it to Egypt where he then acts as the as
the savior of Egypt and then he then
acts as the savior of his people when
they they finally come back to that to
him as the center okay so maybe that's
an example of someone who who remains in
the center but kind of at the same time
will travel because he's it's like the
seed being cast out whereas King David
is really this the story of this kind of
wild outsider who is khuda who's very
he's a shepherd he's the lowest of the
low
he's also he acts crazy he does all this
crazy stuff you know he marries the the
he marries other people's wives he
pretends to be an enemy he he dances
naked in front he does all this crazy
stuff but then he kind of brings things
back you know and then we you know
founds Jerusalem and founds the holy
city and so this kind of going to the
edge and bringing back okay I don't know
how else to say it like every character
is a different play on on the same the
kind of the same story of this you know
this move away and is coming back and in
the terms of Joseph you kind of follow
the center out and then and then and
then you see the coming back of Israel
where as David he goes all the way he's
a wild
while character and he comes and founds
the the holy city
alright so Nick de la Cruz asks I'm you
so sorry if this has been already asked
already
where did george RR martin get his idea
of the overall theme I don't of Game of
Thrones I have not seen it I have I have
not
I've not seen or read Game of Thrones
there's something about it that really
doesn't interest me it's really hard for
me to answer this question because I
haven't seen it the one thing that I've
been told about Nick dela Cruz about
about Game of Thrones and that I buy
what I've seen by what I've grasped I
tend to think that's true that it is a
kind of nihilistic answer to some
someone like token it's like postmodern
deconstruction of the the kind of world
of fantasy which token built and which
has laid itself out in different
different forms this idea of these you
know these different types of people and
these different these kind of these uh
these archetypes you know the mage and
the Paladin of the Paladin or the
barbarian and all these different types
that we find in fantasy which are
actually quite coherent and and a kind
of very little a good way to understand
some traditional symbolism that Game of
Thrones of what I understand tends to
deconstruct all that and alright
alright so risk
Oliver asks as a follow-up to my lower
resolution question about the place of
disagreeable people in the church
oh yeah last month that was last month
what is the center that we might defend
given the diverse history of Christian
interpretation you proposed we joined
church only to attempt to argue with
everyone and st. Christopher style flip
the church's foundational assumptions
from the inside by which I mean any
heretical to a scientific naturalism
fundamentalism mostly I think I speak
for other disagreeable people in
asserting that I don't defend default
institutions okay
Wow alright I would definitely say that
don't do that like really don't do that
it's very it's really really not would
not be helpful for you if you join a
church if you convert if you if you are
chris mated if you're baptized if you
join a church the first thing you need
to do is shut up and listen that's the
first thing you need to do not saying
turn off your you're not saying turn off
your brain I'm not saying turn off your
critical ability none of that none of
that but the first thing in to do is
just shut up and learn to play the game
before you start to criticize the rules
learn to play the game learn to learn
what this is all about
you know you know find your place in the
community and then I know you're gonna
hate me for saying this but then after
several years then you can start to have
influence in that community and
hopefully by then you will have gained
the wisdom to have influence in that
community in a manner that will be
helpful to that community and when I say
helpful to that community I don't mean I
don't mean in helping people become
scientific naturalist that's not what I
mean
how can I say this ok I know this might
be hard for some people to think to
understand but this stuff that I'm
talking about this symbolism stuff I
never talked about this with anybody I
don't talk about this I talk about this
with you guys I put these on on YouTube
for people who are interested in in in
discovering this and I figure the the
subject is difficult enough and it's
it's strange enough and it's kind of a
obtuse enough that only people who are
really interested in this will will even
have the capacity to pay attention and
watch my video
but if I go to church and I meet the
little old lady you know who's there
who who I don't know came from Russia
five years ago I have no interest in
questioning her assumptions at all
because those things they don't they in
everyday life they don't matter what
really matters is how we are with each
other what really matters is how we're
able to engage in the life and be
transformed as people and transform
others not in the sense of transforming
the way they think first of all but
transforming each other in the way we
act towards each other and the way that
we engage with each other now once
you're there for several years and once
you're there for a long time in that
church you will have deciphered the
people in the parish in your in your
actual church who have the interest and
the capacity to talk about symbolism
where the interest in the capacity to
understand things at a more deeper level
and to under and to to go further and
then you can engage those people in
discussion it and you can hash it out
with them as much as you want but but
it's really really ok for the little
lady and for most people in churches to
not have a intellectually deep
understanding of this stuff they don't
have to they oh they need to understand
it to the extent that it train changes
their life and to the extent that it
that it helps them get closer to other
people in their community and and and
makes them want to pray and want to to
engage in the spiritual life but that's
what that's what that's what matters
guys all right where it says sorry if
it's a hard question I like getting my
money's worth
hahaha like I said don't turn off your
brain if you do go to a church don't
turn off your brain and you might go to
a church and be in that church and
realize it you just can't do it you
can't there are some churches that exist
around me there are some churches that
I've been to in my life that I could
never go there ever I couldn't I you
know I can respect the people I can
admire their faith
can admire the way that they take care
of the poor that they help each other
but the the III just couldn't and one of
the reasons why I go to an Orthodox
Church is because the the effect that
single individuals can have on the very
shape of the church is rather limited
the way that the liturgy slays itself
out the art the architecture the history
the tradition is so strong that there's
very little that some idiotic pastor who
doesn't understand anything could do to
change that you know and and you do get
priests at a horrible horrible priests
monstrous priests that are idiots that
are stupid that that have bad intentions
that are that are subversive all of that
exists in the Orthodox Church but the
the capacity they have to affect the
actual functioning of the parish is
limited because of of the tradition so
that's why
all right Jeffy Jeffrey muta asked the
Bible being a story composed of many
stores what exactly is a story what is
the purpose of a story whoa why can't
your face moral story with scientific
facts such as the story that porcupines
further quilts has truth in it but it is
functionally a lie and should it be
replaced by a factor of about porcupine
why shouldn't we do this about the Bible
well first of all I've been wanted to go
after this question for a long time
first of all this story this whole brent
weinstein thing he's just written
weinstein you know he's a very smart
person and and when he talks about you
know the little finch and this this this
strange devel you know this strange
behavior and certain animals and whatnot
but i think that he's he's rather genius
and he's very interesting but when he
talks about human human structures and
hierarchies and stories and morality and
especially religion i think that he
doesn't understand he doesn't understand
what's going on I'm sorry so the purpose
of a story is to is okay
this way stories are ways to fine-tune
and to give you a taste of the pattern
of reality okay and so think of a story
as a reduced you know a think of the
pattern of reality as as so big and so
encompassing that it that and so just so
overwhelming that it's very difficult to
access it you know and only saints only
people who who reach you know spiritual
illumination will access that so think
of a story as a condensed version of
something which gives you a flavor a
taste of a certain pattern okay and it
sounds very esoteric but but not
necessarily so think of a you know think
of a of a of a joke that you've heard
think of any little story that you tell
it's there to kind of condense some and
so it doesn't so the thing is that
stories don't necessarily have to be
moral they don't necessarily have to
have a moral and that's I think one of
the one of the problems with with the
the reducing of the Bible to to ethics
because there are stories in the Bible
that don't have a moral directly in the
sense that you know they kind of embody
they show you a certain pattern and it's
kind of consequences of certain
behaviors and certain interactions and
they show that to you but it's not it's
not necessarily that always that they're
it's trying to tell you what's right and
wrong whatever and so it's the same for
all kinds of stories stories don't
necessarily have to have morals the
reason why you can't you can't replace a
story with just scientific facts is that
what scientific facts and so in in the
case of the
the porcupines you throw their quills
that's not a story
porcupines the idea of porcupines throw
their quills is not a story porcupines
throw their quills is is a statement of
a fact and and and it's a fact which
it's a way of describing it's just a
description of reality which is
important because it's there to protect
you description of reality which has a
certain effect which is to to make
people stop touching porcupines okay now
that's not that's not a that's not a
story and I think that that it shows it
shows us that Bret Weinstein doesn't
understand what stories are he also
doesn't understand what the Bible is
when he he uses this silly example about
porcupines and their quills to talk
about religious stories you know what
does this have to do with Christ you
know talking about Christ going to see
John the Baptist and then being baptized
in the Jordan and coming out and the
bird you know landing on his head what
does that have to do what does this have
to do with like porcupine throwing their
quills and how and how it's it's a it's
a heuristic way of talking about some
factual thing that that is not totally
factual in a in a scientific way it just
just doesn't just doesn't uh does it
help me you can't you can you you could
tell stories you can tell stories today
that you would use only scientifically
proven facts and you could tell stories
that would fit the patterns that
traditional stories have you could do
that totally if you wanted to let me
fine but I but it but but because
because because the stories are not
meant to be scientific descriptions of
reality then I don't really see why we
would do that I don't see what use it
would have all right Tony Solorzano asks
would you ever do a video series about a
Saints story patronage sacramental
metal etc yeah sure I would be happy at
some point to do that I feel like
there's so many things that I want to
talk about that I just kind of have to
get through them slowly slowly slowly
I'm hoping I mean we'll see how it goes
that I'm hoping that this year I'm going
to figure out oh I'm already doing it I
figure out a way to I've hired someone
to help me with my carving you know a
lot of the the patronage that everybody
has been supporting it with has been so
helpful because for a while I thought
that I could I'd have to cut down on my
carving and I really didn't want to do
that because you know I'm I'm one of the
only icon Carver's so I thought it's
important that I keep doing that and so
now the fact that that that people are
supporting me on patreon I've been able
to hire a a person to help me with my
carving which will kind of speed up my
carving and I'm also hiring Thomas from
storytellers to edit the at least my
movie videos for now but just next week
we're having a meeting to talk about how
he might be able to take more
responsibility so what I'm hoping to do
is that as if my patronage keeps going
up to a certain extent and I'm able to
hire people to do the different aspects
of what I want to do then I'll be able
to also put out more content and so then
that's then it's at that point we might
be able to have series going on at the
same time so I have like series
criticizing culture but have a series on
stories of the Saints stories of I want
to do like love to do series on fairy
tales I'd love to do you know so maybe
even a series or more on social
commentary and so kind of do these and
so maybe and you know instead of having
two three videos a month have maybe five
six videos a month or maybe more
depending on on how much time I were
able to and I was how much resource I'm
able to put into getting other people
also to to help me with videos my
question is time right now it's like how
can I use the the resources that all of
you guys have been providing me to give
myself more time to be able to do all
the things that I think are important to
do so yes at some point I would be very
happy to do a to do some to do some
Saints stories I like to do some like
some
kind of like more traditional stories a
lot of legends do do kind of I love
explaining like the wild legends yeah
you might have noticed that I like
taking like the craziest thing that
someone that everybody thinks it's so
stupid and so silly about traditional
thought and uh and then explain it to
people that's that's something that
gives me a lot of joy all right
okay so Anne Joe terrip strap says
Einstein stated that he believed in the
god of Spinoza who reveals himself in
the harmony of all that exists he did
not believe in a personal God who
concerns himself with fates and actions
of human beings a view which he
describes as naive does your perception
of God fit into any of these definitions
would you say that your God is a
personal God and in what matter now this
this problem this problem stems from the
problem that I've been trying to help
you guys understand from the beginning
it is the problem of ignoring the
reality of consciousness of acting as if
consciousness has no bearing in the
world acting as if personhood either
didn't exist or isn't important or is
just taken for granted maybe that's
probably the best way to see it to think
as if personhood and and and the point
of self-consciousness is is it's taken
for granted and so then we look out and
we we try to imagine the infinite and
somehow we find it naive to think that
the manner in which I look at the
infinite the manner in which I I had the
only creature that we know of in on
earth who is able to even ponder the
question of the infinite that the
capacity that I have to ponder the
infinite which somehow it is naive to
think that that would somehow mirror the
infinite it's like to me that's just I
don't understand how people can get to
that I don't understand why it bothers
people that that that God is mine that
God is person that God is infinite
consciousness I don't understand why
that bothers people
and so the question the question of the
and the problem the problem is is that
we're so we're so scientific we only
think in in in in a quantitative manners
and so we don't understand we don't
understand how we don't understand how
qualitative things work and so when we
when we think of God who who answers
your prayers the only reason why bothers
us because we have to imagine a God that
is in space and in time somewhere and
he's there you like tabulating a
calculator and he is he's he's answering
your prayers like that's not why does it
have to be that way why if you
participate
mind if you that is your origin why does
it bother you that that you can interact
with that your origin and that origin
can interact with you to me it's maybe
it's like I don't use cuz to me it's I
find that that that people are not like
I said people just take consciousness
for granted and I think that that's the
problem once you start to understand
when you start once you start to put
consciousness back into the the chains
of causalities which is what I'm always
saying then all of a sudden the the
infinite you know the infinite God has
to you that aspect of you has to also
reflect the the the infinite and that's
all I guess that's all I can say and so
I don't have a problem with God
answering prayers at all I don't have a
problem with that at all and I and I and
I know that it happens to people all the
time and I don't have a problem with
miracles I don't have a problem with you
know oh yeah I don't have a problem with
that in any way
all right so Laurie lit Thiago asked
regarding the principles in power
discussion with Paul Vander clay do you
feel like interpreting things in that
vein opens the specter of where exactly
would the more non symbolic
interpretation stop
I see many very deep advantages than
symbolic interpretation but can it
become a slippery slope where the
resurrection itself is only reduced to
symbolism I like the way Pearson has
approaches so far
he seems to try his best to not reduce
it to just the symbolic and
psychological okay so I think this is
probably a really good opportunity for
me to address this question because it's
been a question that has just been going
I think that has been coming back over
and over people write me people ask me
if I believe in the resurrection and and
I've why we watch my video where I talk
about the resurrection again and I don't
know how it is that people get come to
that conclusion
when I use the word symbolism it does
not mean that there's an absence of
manifestation it does not mean that at
all the word symbolism if you want to
know more about that watch them the the
the video that I did with my brother
called what is symbolism where we talk
about how symbolism is this bringing
together the bringing together of
meaning and multiplicity or potentiality
it's the way in which things come
together to have meaning that is simply
words symbol means to bring things
together and so symbolism does not
exclude manifestation and so it's not
it's not that the resurrection is just
symbolic symbolic it's that the
resurrection is the ultimate symbol in
the sense that the resurrection brings
everything together and manifests it
brings all you know all the whole
history of the entire world together
into one event and part of that is that
it had to be an event it had to be an
actual event that happened in the first
century
because if you don't have the particular
then it's missing something it's missing
the particular and so for the reservoir
for Christ to be who Christ is he could
cannot have been just a mythical figure
he cannot have been just have been just
a figment of someone's imagination
Christ has to have had an actual
physical manifestation for him to be
what he is for Christ to be what Christ
is that has had that has to happen and
so the events in the the Bible in the
events and the Gospels are describing
events the the the narrative and the
gospel are describing events that
happened in the world and and and but
that doesn't mean that doesn't mean that
that there isn't mystery in those events
there's definitely mystery even in the
resurrection of Christ there's
definitely mystery and maybe that's why
people have been always wondering
because I - - - I said I want to slap
people around when they think they've
figured out the resurrection I just want
to slap them say no no you don't don't
think you figured out the resurrection
my friend don't think that you've
captured it don't think that you that
you framed it it's like that that story
is a lot bigger than you think
and so I'm not denying that it happened
I'm just saying be careful when people
just just have this mental image in
their mind of you know a dead body just
kind of sitting up and walking out of
the grave like that's not how the story
is told the story is told you know in a
very strange and mysterious way because
it's trying to point to you that this
this that the resurrection is mysterious
it is it is something that that that
that that keeps its mystery within its
own telling so yeah so I think that's
something that I I've been wanting to
say for a little while okay so alright
Michael Parsons asked what is the
difference between Coptic Christianity
and Eastern Orthodoxy yeah so the the
cops are the cops is this technical the
cop
what we call non Caledonian Christians
which means that they don't accept the
Council of Chalcedon you know I it's not
my decision to whether or not we are in
communion with the cops but but I have a
lot of sympathy for the cops and I also
have a lot of sympathy for the mess you
know although I totally agree with kalsa
Don and I am totally in line with the
Council of Chalcedon I think that the
way that it happened the the details of
the way in which it laid laid itself out
I think a lot of it is very messy the
way that the Fathers of the council
changes the which Ange the the terms
that that st. Cyril of Alexandria used
you know anyways it's complicated but
just in theory you know you would say
that most people would say something
like that the north electricians say
that Christ has two natures and the cops
say the Christ has one nature but they
do believe in a kind of duality a kind
of duality in Christ but they don't
formulate it in the same way and it and
it's it's big enough a deal that the two
churches have been out of communion for
ever so but I have a lot of admiration
for Coptic Christianity and and Coptic
Christians as well they they live in
very difficult situation they've been
living in a difficult situation for a
very long time and they you know they
know what it means to you know you go to
church on a Sunday and you don't know if
there's gonna be a bomb it's like would
I go to church on a Sunday if I thought
there might be a bomb I don't know all
right all right so Erin lichtenberger
asks I've been reading Camille Paglia
sexual persona she frames much art as
the endless struggle for mastery by the
masculine over the feminine but also as
the inevitable defeat of the masculine
by the feminine I don't see these themes
in religious art in part because I'm not
an artist but also because the union of
both seems to be a heavy emphasis
interview how did it happen that the
religious symbols of you
in both give way to our depicting
struggle that's a really huge question
I've mentioned this if you listen to the
last Q&A I talked a little bit about
this I talked about how the modern age
is a you could see it as a DEA
incarnation that is the you see the
pendulum swing in art you can see it in
art between something you could call a
classical I'm using words you can use
other words but let's say a classical
tendency and a baroque tendency which is
a kind of order
you know perfection everything tied up
in a nice little go and then a kind of
loose let's say more expressive more
kind of let's say sublime vision and so
you see it go back and forth you had
this kind of Renaissance which which at
first is super strict and it goes into
the Baroque then it goes into
neoclassicism then he goes into the
romanticism then you get kind of social
realist crazy you know kind of fascist
art then you also have kind of modernism
and this decadent you know with the you
know the with the with the with the
Nazis called degenerate art you know
they had the hyper crazy order like
hyper classicism the Nazis ad there was
also this kind of crazy degenerate art
on the other side and so it's like you
see this pendulum swing back and forth
and so and so so yeah I think that's
what it is I think it's it's just the
move the slow move away from the
Incarnation and all that it all that it
entailed all right Kevin Martin asked in
your conception in what ways is the
Antichrist most usefully symbolized and
where does it lay hierarchically
relative to Christ presumably at the
same strata and what is the most
practical relationship for each of us to
have with Antichrist presumably one of
informed responsibility
Wow yeah that's that's really it's very
tough that's very tough
in what ways is it most usefully
symbolized a good way to see here's a
way that I could say it doesn't
encompass everything but here's an
interesting way that I could say that
maybe a lot of people hadn't thought
about which is something like
Christianity without Christ could be a
way to see Antichrist there are other
ways but if we look at the first
Antichrist if we look at Judas we look
at the way that Judas acted in relation
to Christ now it's very interesting
because Judas betrayed Christ but
there's a scene for example where Judas
where we're a you know a sinful woman
comes to wash Christ's feet and then
Jews it Judas criticizes Christ for
doing that and he says what does he say
he says how can you accept this we
should have we should have given the
perfume this very expensive perfume sold
it and given the money to the poor and I
think that that is a that's that's a
nice image of the spirit of Antichrist a
kind of Christian values without Christ
and you see that right now I think in
the the kind of extreme
would you call mainline Protestant
churches you kind of see this this move
towards an obsession with social justice
and in an obsession with social
questions but a a turn away from the
essential aspect of the church which is
to come into communion in worship before
God and also be transformed personally
by our experience of communion and our
you know our interaction with in the
life with church and is rather turned
towards now I'm not saying of course
Christians shouldn't help the poor of
course they should Christ told us we
should help the poor
this but this is the trick of Antichrist
which is to to kind of give us something
a kind of Christianity without Christ um
and so you know what is our what is our
most how can we be responsible towards
that now okay let's say this way
Antichrist is you know I talked about
the double inversion everybody has heard
me talk about that if you're listening
to this tonight you've probably heard
this heard me talk about the double
inversion I think that that's something
that can be done with the spirit of
Antichrist I think that when we
encounter people who talk about
Christianity without Christ I think we
can flip it back and and bring it back
to Christ and so if you've noticed
that's what I've been doing hopefully
people can I can only say it's for those
who have ears to hear all right okay so
Kevin Martin asked what relationship do
you see between psychological reality
and the hype hype petha sized objective
material reality or do you not assume
that both of these exist okay so I think
I think I think the problem is
psychological reality and objective
material reality I think that I think
that we have to see this psychological
as an intern intermediary aspect but
there is the Church Fathers talk about a
higher aspect of the human being which
we call the noetic aspect you could call
the spiritual aspect of the human being
and that noetic aspect is our capacity
to grasp reality for what it is it is
our capacity to intuitively see and so
when I talk about when I
talk about how we engage the world and
how the human being participates in the
manner in which the world lays itself
out I'm not talking about psychological
reality I'm not talking about what we
think you know I'm not saying that we
can make the world into whatever we want
you know I'm not a not a sorcerer but
what I'm talking about is this noetic
capacity which is before thought before
before rationalization it's this
intuitive capacity and so we don't
actually often have access to it because
we're blind we just we just see the
world but with practice at some point
you can start to within with prayer and
with practice with meditation you can
start to to see this interaction you can
see the know you can see how the Logie
of the world are kind of gathered in to
us st. Maximus talks about how we are
the laboratory you know for all of this
world to come kind of be joined together
in us and then you know that essentially
that is what God created us for us to
kind of join all this together
and and sometimes you can see hints of
it in the psychological which is I do
use sometimes arguments that that
referred to more psychological aspects
and how we can get a hint sometimes
because we can see people you know twist
reality with with kind of psychological
arguments we're seeing that right now
like you know we see it in the media a
lot is how you know using psychological
tactics using using persuasion tactics
people are trying to magically shape the
world so that you only see the world
only exists in a certain frame for
certain people you know they're in the
matrix you should say something like
that you know and so and so that's right
so once we start to understand this we
can see also how how through the
psychological it can be misused but also
through the psychological sometimes you
can you can break through someone and
kind of
open up their their their perception I
think so they can see things connect
together and you can create these kind
of surprises um that's okay so do I
assume that both of these exists like I
like I don't know I don't objective
material reality so the are you asking
like if things exist without new she
would say without spirit I don't think
things exist without spirit I think that
the the the existence of the world is a
joining of heaven and earth - joining of
the Spirit of God and the potentiality
the of the the lower waters or whatever
you know and I think that that's how the
world exists and that's what it's like
in Genesis and that's what it's like
when God creates Adam and and and that's
what it's like when when you know it's
like that's just how how the world
exists but that doesn't depend on
individual people you know that let's
say the noetic aspect or the the logos
in you or the logos is the it ultimately
all this points to divine logos
ultimately all this whole process points
to the divine logos but without the
Divine Word without without without the
essence which is spoken by God and then
at a lower level through Christ and
through us through Christ I I think that
I think that the whole idea of whether
existed it just becomes irrelevant I
don't even know what that would mean
without that I hope this makes sense I
hope I'm not I feel like those questions
are a little bit difficult so all right
so Michael Parsons asked hey Jonathan I
just finished the AFL talk
that's the ancient faith live talk that
I gave on Sunday it's called faith
encouraged if you guys want to check it
out you can find it on the ancient faith
website said wondering if you would do a
video on the sacraments and the
Eucharist in the future also I remember
you meant
you would be giving a talk in Dallas yes
I might be giving a talk in Dallas it's
not totally confirmed when my probably
in February hopefully that'll work out I
will keep you guys posted you know just
say follow me on Twitter and Facebook
and my website I'll be I'm putting up
the dates on all of my talks on my
website now so so keep an eye on that if
I would do a video on the sacrament of
the Eucharist yeah of course I
definitely that's one of the things I
want to do for sure one of my many
subjects that I'd like to talk about
all right so Daniel brew ass I don't
really know how to ask this question I
grew up in a Protestant church which had
a very strong emphasis on heaven and
hell and not much of any focus on heaven
and earth this seems to result in time
on earth being seen as simply a waiting
room yes and exactly what you mean do
you have any thoughts on how this might
be related to having a more
materialistic interpretation of
Christianity it strange because heaven
and hell cannot be material things and
yet are the core foundations of so many
creationist fundamentalist type
Christians yes is this a problem solved
by the multiple levels of interpretation
as metru writes about in his book cosmic
individual communal inter-communal what
is a healthy view of heaven and hell
okay how can I talk about this well
first of all for sure I think that the
idea that the idea of the earth is being
a symbol of this weird waiting-room is
definitely something that is problematic
its pop it is it it is problematic and
it does come from a materialistic
interpretation of Christianity and it
definitely comes from a lack of
believing that there's a ontological
reality of how the world exists and how
Christ part is the source of that and
how we are been to participate in that
and and that our life in the world is is
there for us to be united with Christ is
there for us to be joined with Christ
and manifest Christ in the world be free
be free from sin be free
from from our thoughts freeze free from
from our our passions you know or at
least transform our not free but like
transform our passion so that they're
like this burning divine fire in us
that's what we're called to you know you
read the lives of the saints and you you
see that they're transform beings that
that's the that's the purpose of this
life is to to live as much as we can in
in the life of Christ and so and so the
idea that that you just believe in Jesus
and that you're saved and then you're
just basically here to evangelize other
people until you die and then you go to
heaven that is just like such a
mechanistic it's like it is it's like
kind of here I believe in these
arbitrary things which actually aren't
descriptions of reality you know and I
just believe them on faith you know and
it's like no Christianity is a
description of the reality I keep
telling people that like it's a
description of how things work you know
it's it's different from the scientific
description but it's coherent and it's
describing how we're meant to be how it
how the world lays itself out and so how
to talk about heaven and hell now
there's so many problems like hell is
death that's what hell is in in the at
the outset hell is is is let's say it's
it's Hades okay and so we art until
death what death is the breaking a part
of the cohesion that's what death is
it's it's fragmentation it's it's a it's
a it's a breaking a part of of it's a
separation of heaven and earth creation
is a joining of heaven and earth and
then when having a nurse starts to
separate then that creates this breaking
apart decomposition of the lower of the
of the lower part of manifestation
that's yes that's that's that's
decomposing that's being exiled from the
garden that's living becoming
animalistic you know being torn up
from the passions all of that is that's
that's it
that's hell that's that's that's death
and so there is a difference I'll say
between death and Gehenna or the fire
lefty at the end of time that the
eternal fire you could say there's a
difference between those two but death
that's what death is is this this kind
of this is breaking apart and so in a
way it is you could see it as in a way
the opposite of heaven in the sense that
it is when we lose our purpose when we
lose when we miss the mark right when
when we talk about this that sin is
missing the mark it's missing the
bullseye going towards the edge it kind
of falling apart and that's what it is
and so that's that's the relationship
between let's say heaven and hell or
heaven and death as for the idea of gano
or the eternal fire if you want to know
about that watch the video that I did on
the icon of the Last Judgement I I go
into that at length in that discussion
and talk about you know what are some
possible interpretations of last
judgment and of Gehenna all right okay
so raid Petric Patricia Patricia I think
sorry if I mispronounced your name right
hi John I think you talked about the
hierarchy of sin and passions and how
this connects the idea of the different
levels of hell thank God and thanks and
God bless yes
the you see that especially in in Dante
but I think Dante does a really good job
at expressing this idea of this this you
could call it an upside down hierarchy
of sin and so the world you know for
there to be an order there they're there
to be something there has to be a kind
of hierarchy and so the best that death
best that sin can do is D an upside down
hierarchy and so we have this idea of in
Dante you have these different levels of
hell and did lower the closer you get
towards you know the devil himself and
the closer you get towards the the
middle of the earth then the the
or the sins ar-ar-ar-ar how the bigger
the sins are and so the sins of the
passions are usually actually not that
low they're not that high on the sins of
hierarchy because they're they're kind
of sins of volition their sins of
distraction their sins of uh of kind of
losing control of yourself and so a grey
to understand it for example is that the
highest end in the hierarchy is a sin of
pride it's a wise at the sin of pride
because like anything that's at the top
of a hierarchy it is the cause it is the
source it is the essence it's like an
upside down essence of all the other
sins that is you can get rid of all the
sins and you could all do it through
pride you could still have pride and
pride is the cause of all the other sins
then all the other sense is gonna be
taken up into being an example of pride
because it is always a self sufficiency
with it that makes us sin it's always a
a wanting to be alone like in our
wanting to be self-sufficient in
ourselves be self causing that's what
always brings about the other sins like
you lie because you you you stop
considering the other you you just think
about your own desires you know and you
think that your desires have priority
over the desires of the others you know
you kill somebody for the same reason
all the sins can be kind of brought up
into pride and so that's why that's why
pride is at the top of the of the sin
hierarchy now in Dante he doesn't put
pride at the top of the sin hierarchy he
puts betrayal at the top of the sin
hierarchy um and I think he does it I
think he does it I mean he does it
because he's because of what happened to
him I think in part because he was
betrayed and because he was betrayed by
his fellow his fellow citizens in in
Florence is was he from Florence I think
so and and he does it too because I
think that in a way
trail there could be there's also pride
in betrayal you know you could see that
as well like that if you if you if you
betray it's like you you do it a lot
purpose like you plan it like you not
only you hurt someone but you really do
it out of spite and guile and everything
but at least it take to take the the
idea that there is this hierarchy of
sins I think is important and to
understand that if you give out if you
give yourselves two to two different
sins then those have those have
different consequences alright alright
yeah we got through all the questions on
the patreon Q&A so let me go into the
chat and see if we got some interesting
questions here so
herb father asks hi Jonathan Petro I
wanted to ask you if had any thoughts
about people like Milo and Owen Benjamin
criticizing jbp recently they both
insinuate jbp doesn't stick to his
principles and point to the talent
agency jvp signed up to as evidence of
jvp selling out yeah there are a few
things about that it's like one of the
problems I think that that like someone
like Owen Benjamin has is that he he
just idealized Jordan too much you know
it's like I I like a lot of things that
Jordan is doing and I think that I think
well first of all I think is the real
deal like you know I I tell people he's
not any different in private than he is
in public he's he's extremely attentive
he's extremely he cares for people that
he encounters and he wants to help
people like he desperately wants to help
people and he goes out of his way to
help people when when he can um you know
a good example they just happened
recently you know Paul Van der clays
sister died suddenly
you know she had small children she she
died of a heart attack she was it she's
like in her early
40 she's in her 40s I think and she had
young children and so it's like Jordan
barely knows who paul van de clay is you
know it's like he probably knows that
there's this pastor making videos about
him somehow or somewhat and so I just
wrote him and I said oh you know paul
banach Lee's sister died she was quite
young and it's not like his wife died or
his child died is his sister who died
and so I wrote him and I said that and
yeah and Jordan reached out to Paul
wrote him a little email condolences and
it's like that's Jordan that's how
that's what Jordan is um and so I think
that in the in the case of Owen Benjamin
I think that the things that he points
out like the kind of weird stuff like
how Jordan lied because he said that he
didn't sleep for 30 days and so how can
someone say that it's a lie or that that
Jordan lied because he said that he
could get here over that he wrote each
sense in his book you know you know 15
times or whatever and it's like dude man
can you don't you can't you see the
difference between hyperbole and lying I
mean obviously has anybody just it's
like when you say I haven't slept all
night that that usually that that
doesn't necessarily mean that you didn't
sleep here and there 15 minutes five you
don't even know because a sleepless
night drives you crazy so when he said I
didn't sleep for 30 days it's like he
doesn't necessarily mean that he
actually didn't sleep for little amounts
of time really he was sleepless for
thirty days and so you could kind of
Nick pick out silly things like that and
say that he's a that he's a liar like I
don't think I think Jordan obviously
lies just like anybody I think he lies
and I think that like everybody he
sometimes might act in a way to protect
himself just like we all do and that you
know that he might have said some things
at some points he might have you know
like for example people talk about the
faith golde thing and and how he through
faith Goldie under the bus and it's like
he really struggled with that he did it
wasn't easy for him
I remember he even talked to me like he
was went out of the way to say like you
know we talked about it and and we
didn't know and it was the time was
coming and he was like the day was
happening and you know what to do
because we we didn't we didn't have all
the facts and we weren't sure and so we
decided to do it this way and he said
well we'll stick by what we decided but
at the same time it's not like it was
just this
easy thing that he did like that and you
can criticize him you can say you
shouldn't have done that or you should
have but to say that it's just like this
big manipulation and it's just like big
horrible plot of him to be a globalist
and or whatever it's like it's just
silly
that stuff is silly and I think Milo I
think it's really too bad I think Milo I
think it's too bad what he did if you
read that if you read the article that
Milo wrote about Jordan it's all about
himself it's all about Milo and it and
how Jordan didn't stand up for Milo and
how Jordan had called Milo urine had
called Milo and you know you know what
you know what the reason why Jordan even
paid any attention to Milo is because me
I brought Milo up right away the first
times I met with him I was at his house
when Jordan called talked to Milo on the
phone it's like I I was telling Jordan
he should pay attention to my luggage
because I thought he was an important
character and and and Jordan asked Milo
when when the whole scandal around my
love did Jordan said Milo why don't you
come on my channel we'll talk about it
you know we'll do well dissect it we'll
go through it and maybe it can help to
you know to kind of help people
understand what happened in what you
said and everything and and and Milo
didn't do it he didn't he didn't want to
do it and so and then Jordan Jesus went
on his life and when Jordan said that he
hadn't been paying attention to Milo it
was true that he had been paying
attention to Marlowe who's busy doing
his own thing and Milo had dropped off
the map and so I just find that I just
find it annoying I just find that that
that I think it's kind of sad I think
it's kind of sad that Milo went that way
and when he says things like that Jordan
is only spouting gibberish and that he's
only that his he's not what he's saying
doesn't make sense it's like you're just
putting a huge gigantic foot in your
mouth Milo like I respect Milo he's
smart and and he said some he said some
things that are very important done some
things that are very important but like
when you say that it's like I understand
everything Jordan says I've never
understood
you think Jordan has ever said that I
don't understand and so you can call me
an idiot and you can call everybody who
actually understand what Jordan says an
idiot but it's that's not helpful it's
not helpful and and and like I've told
you guys and I've said it publicly and I
said it to Jordan there are plenty of
things that we can criticize about
Jordan Pederson you know he is not he is
not a Christian he he he has strange
ideas about Christianity he he has I
think he misunderstands some aspects of
post-modernism I think that he
misunderstands all kinds of things the
problem happens when we idealize people
way too much and then we all this under
surprise when they don't they don't
they're not in line with how we idealize
them it's like Jordan is a important
voice and we should pay attention to him
and we should help him out when he's
doing the right things but it's like
don't don't base your life on during
Peterson guys it's just it's not that's
not gonna help you alright and in terms
of the talent agency is one of those
things again it's like it's one of those
things again this idea that somehow
everybody should be aware of every of
all the conspiracy theories it's like
Jordan's probably signed with CAA
distante agency out there and they could
offer him what he wanted and so he said
okay sure I'll sign the CAA if you can
get me the gigs if you can sign up the
places then I'll go and I'll say what I
want to say and it's like that's
probably why he's signed with CAA
because he needed he wanted to do this
world tour and who else can organize a
world tour it's like it's very difficult
to do that and so so the idea that
somehow he's in line with globalism and
that because CAA is a dark organization
that that's why he's it's like all of
that is just and it's the same with the
UN it's like he went to the UN because
they probably invited him and said they
would they they would let him speak to
the UN he's like okay well speak to the
UN hey why not if the if the president
of if Justin Trudeau invites them to his
office and says I'd like to talk with
you Jordan be like yeah okay like you
know what Mark Zuckerberg wanted to call
Jordan and she was like okay I'll talk
to Mark Zuckerberg like Jordan just will
talk to anybody
he's so just because he talks to Mark
Zuckerberg or just because he goes to
the UN doesn't mean that he agrees with
them and this is the
problem with people are so crazy today
it's like just because you talk with
someone even if you because even if
you're friends with someone doesn't mean
that you agree with everything they say
it's like I I am friends with Joran
Peterson I am way more conservative than
he is I am way more I'm even more
right-leaning than he is I'm more I'm
more I'm definitely more a Christian
than his I'm not I don't I'm not a fan
of the Enlightenment I'm a more a
medievalist like all these things can
exist and I can still talk to him and I
can still find some of the best stuff
that that he does and see it as
something that's good it's like people
just have to be more subtle anyways
sorry I just feel like today I'm going
into a lot of grant type conversations
sorry about that guys all right Hamilton
provancha
Hamilton good to see you man can you
comment on the nationalistic icon in the
Ukraine where as saying George is
vanquishing the two-headed Eagle so
Hamilton
I saw Hamilton a few months ago and he
was the one to show me this icon so he
wants me to now give my opinion on that
I think it's very disturbing anybody
who's seen he can look it up it's very
very disturbing I'm not sure exactly
what it means you know it's like because
the two-headed Eagle just represents
kind of Christian civilization and
represent Constantinople it represents
the Holy Roman Emperor remember that
there's like what is st. George doing
exactly it's like you're destroying he's
he's destroying Christian to the
Christian Imperium he is destroying you
know I don't know I don't know what that
what that means so so it's very
disturbing
yeah all right guys all right so I think
I think so kangaroo media asked a bunch
of questions which I don't really have
an answer I have you seen John wick I
think I did see it but I didn't I didn't
I I think I was barely paying attention
to it it's just like this this kind of
action movie
have you read Ernst Kassar and his
philosophy of symbolic forms Jason I can
call you takes him I know I have not
read it so I would not have anything to
say to that all right guys I would be
going for an hour and a half so so sorry
if I can feel like I bet a lot of the
answers I didn't I was kind of ranty
today so sorry about that if I was kind
of kind of annoying but uh yeah I've
been tired these days just it's like the
Sun is so low it's like the Solstice
needs to happen pretty soon so we can
get some more sunlight and also snow
there's no snow usually in in November
and now it's just there's snow all the
time just yeah just in a weird mood so
so guys thanks for for for hanging out
and yeah
pay attention like I said I think I told
everybody I'm next video is going to be
on the gremlins
so I'm looking forward to that I already
did I did a podcast about that last year
and so I was I really had to wait when
so I'm gonna I want to make a video
based on that and and so when you saw
that I put up some a lot of people have
been asking me for like merchandise and
stuff so I put up some some merch on on
uh there's on teespring
and so and other people criticize it cuz
it's kind of not high quality it's like
yeah I know I know it's just just
standard stuff just for people who
wanted you know to have a bit of fun and
identify with what we're doing but I am
working on better stuff soon I want to I
want you to I'm going to expand my told
you guys that I hired an assistant and
so I'm going to expand my artistic
production to have more general more
general imagery let's say kind of maybe
do a few medieval monsters a few images
of uh you know likes maybe some cherubs
or something like you know just just
stuff that that is more general and and
hopefully you'll be more accessible for
a lot of people watching the videos as
well so um so guys thanks for thanks for
for coming out and yeah thanks for all
your support and yeah we keep on keeping
on so I'll see you guys in December bye